well basically right now that freeze is
still in effect on that band that was
put in place on sunday thanks to that
executive order from President Donald
Trump but as far as the details it was a
29-page ruling by those three judges
over the Ninth Circuit Court all three
of them ruling unanimously to continue
the freeze of this immigrant travel ban
and in a tweets as expected president
Trump reacted with in about half an hour
or so after that ruling came comment
came out in an all-caps you can see
there see you in court he said the
security of our nation is at stake very
quickly after that the legal team for
Washington State arguing on behalf of
immigrants as well as businesses came
back and said that this was a win and
praise that decision take listen the
Ninth Circuit Court of Appeals in a
unanimous decision effectively granted
everything we saw it we are a nation of
laws and as I have said as we have said
from day one that those laws apply to
everybody in our country and that
includes the president of the United
States it's the role of the courts to
say what the law is and to serve as a
check on the executive branch and that's
what the court has done in this opinion
in this excellent opinion this well
reasoned careful thoughtful opinion that
seriously considered all the
government's arguments and rejected them
that man just now was a Noah Purcell the
Solicitor General of Washington State
who actually argued to that Ninth
Circuit Court of Appeals just a couple
days ago but looking also at reaction
from Congress there's not too much and
interestingly rich the Republicans are
seem to be fairly quiet and we've only
gotten one Democratic congressman coming
out of this and that would happen to be
a Democratic Senate Minority Leader
Chuck Schumer and he's basically saying
that this decision and this push at
least by the White House is
unconstitutional and he's pushing for
the president to come out with a
bipartisan plan that you can see there
but again a lot of people at least on
the Republican Republican side staying
on the sidelines for now as this case
wines to court
ramie tell us about the ramifications
here of this decision yeah well for one
it first off is a victory for immigrants
of course those immigrants coming from
the seven majority of Muslim country is
mostly from the Middle Eastern North
Africa but on the business side we have
to look at that it's also a win for
businesses that rely heavily on
immigrant talent immigrant innovation
that they say you'll remember that's on
Sunday night about 97 Silicon Valley
companies assign an MS amicus brief to
the Ninth Circuit saying that their
businesses would be hurt by this band
that includes google facebook as well as
apple and by one account one out of
three this is interesting one out of
three silicon valley residents rich are
actually foreign-born two out of three
math and technical workers in the
Silicon Valley area are also
foreign-born according to one study so
it's interesting to see the reliance
here but looking ahead we do have more
court cases if this doesn't go
immediately to the Supreme Court it'll
fall back to Washington State to sort of
hash out the finer details on what to do
next if the Supreme Court does get an
appeal and they take it up we could see
that happen but remember that the court
is divided four and four in terms of
Republican as well as Democratic
presidential appointees so that could
very well be a stalemate if it comes
down according to a political ideology
rich